hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Dan
Seibert let's get one thing clear you
know like Dan's here does I'm not the
biggest gamer in the world all right
people think like I try to come off as
one and I'm like there are times where I
made it pretty clear I don't really know
what I'm talking and maybe that that's
my thing is I just like the [ __ ]
hackers I used to had a toss I used to
play a lot of Nintendo I used to play a
lot of Super Nintendo and I was a huge
n64 fan PlayStation PlayStation 2 and
then I went like really broke because I
tried being an adult got an Xbox 360 but
I just never get around really planning
many games there's one game
I [ __ ] love and I played the first
three people have been saying so much
that I have to watch this for the
longest time this trailers been out
forever
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain it's
all the way from e3 2013 read ban and I
still get a bunch of people asking me to
check this out this is our retro yeah
retro grave you guys did two years ago
are you guys ready for something awesome
because this is one of the all these
[ __ ] kids I'm gonna murder these kids
I'm just two of them I'm gonna know
there's like five of them I won't just
murder - the other ones will shut up
backwards I do not condone child murder
biggie 18 the following trailer is a
porn trailer
because when they're ready recruits just
a contact
rubbing our noses in bloody battlefield
dirt
ultra revenge
this game has the best cinema oh it does
Oh
oh come on
uh-huh if she works to it yeah it was
consensual wow those look like real
people
it almost didn't I didn't go there yo
every night I can feel my leg my
my fingers
Oh God the body of lost the comrades
headlock
don't you
give back our past
Oh all God he's still alive
this is Mike's killing over a long time
oh my god there was c-4 inside and that
was a she
wasn't super
you
it's not just that whole world wants you
dead you'll have to join up McMiller
build that private are
firstly this is
Miller he's in Afghanistan gasps your
alleged in the eyes of those who live on
the battlefield that's why you have to
handle this mission yourself
I tell cause would want it
Afghanistan is a big place
I expect you become quite familiar with
those binoculars as you play in your
next move how and where you make any use
productive that's what I'm assuming yeah
now go let the legend come back to life
oh then ready the gameplay the gameplay
graphics match the movie graphics pretty
well holy crap open-world mgs huh cat
new briefs
horse tell horse Delft
feels very uh
like red deadbeats Metal Gear Solid
which I'm totally okay with
there they are
human face
you
why
realistic passage of time with a giant
box right mix you
is it like when you turn off the game or
something it's realistic fast at the
time
I don't know Oh records [ __ ]
hi
all those guys have to die come on
the graphics make it that much more
intense
I like that I still prefer David haters
voice
although this is a different snakes yeah
whoo she's my glasses bro
took you so long she's gonna be fun
so face
sins of the father
calls for wet work and we answered no
greater good
no Just Cause
mine
sico service to help but we're going
even deeper take back everything we've
lost because I'm already a demon me is
what still is pretty cool
oh you mentioned something interesting
cyber is pursuing new research he claims
of what they're doing at the pays the
miss a dose a weapon to surpass metal
here even bigger one that like a weapon
that could surpass metal gear that's
pretty free tips I mean metal gears
Metal Gear Solid and me metal gears the
most intense thing in the world I
remember playing Metal Gear Solid and
then versing the Metal Gear on
PlayStation where the controls were much
more limited than when they rebooted it
on GameCube and it was like the most
terrifying experience in my life but
then in part two I remember they made
you fight like 20 metal years because
we're intimidated one-minute orgy well
yeah I guess you can't have do a Metal
Gear this storytelling behind Metal Gear
Solid is just so [ __ ] impressive like
people have been saying they should get
a movie together they should get a movie
together and Hideo Kojima's like yeah we
got they're always saying we have it we
got I really don't think they need a
movie because the game is already so
much of a movie it's in the details of
the hours of story dude I was gonna say
like half the visuals in that are better
than half the visuals that are in movies
these days yeah absolutely like these
graphics are better than most that I've
seen on current gen current being like
the one we're on now ps4 px Box one like
the only thing that's close to that is
the other game that Kojima worked on PT
silent hill's oh you see only other
thing that looks as good game looks so
[ __ ] good sorry I was reading a
report about collider.com recently about
the Metal Gear Solid movie and I think
that if they do that it's like imagine
Lord of the Rings and they were like
let's just put it in one movie like all
three stories oh no I mean I told ya I
totally the the storyline for metal
your solid tradition is really complex
yeah it's complex you have to play the
other games to really know what the [ __ ]
is going on
you have to read like you have to pay
attention in this series more than you
have to do with most games to understand
what's not [ __ ] it it's like keeping up
with the three Matrix movies and key in
making sure I know everything so
everything's understood it's hours of
character and that's other things like
there character-driven stories those are
the best kind of movies sure but it's
already a movie in itself sure if you're
sure and it's ready in English for us we
don't need a redo day they already came
a over translate for us 25 Kiefer
Sutherland is a good snake mm-hmm I just
prefer the original snake voice Metal
Gear Metal Gear you see the crab battle
via the way the crab battle video no I
gotta show you that actually let's just
end that with the crab battle video I've
seen it but Dan has it if you do the
challenge you can subscribe to the real
rejects dan has a gaming channel called
that cyber channel check it out a lot of
fun and you can follow us on Instagram
Twitter and Facebook yeah if you want to
split it to east and west
this marks the beginning of an era known
as the cool just wait Dan I'm wearing
wait
hope this videos as good as everybody
god I miss the days of like old flash
animation
it's a what
yeah
eyeballs speaking out Marshall
what
is family